I thought I told you to go to bed.
You told me to go to bed, you didn't say get into bed.
Milo!
I shouldn't have said what I said.
I'm gonna go tell her I'm sorry right now.
Mom? Mom? Mom! Let her go!
Ah! Let me go!
I'm in a spaceship.
48 million miles from home.
Welcome to Mars.
What is going on?
Mars needs moms.
The aliens are stealing them from Earth to raise their own kids.
One Earthling has one night...
Less than seven hours?
...to save Earth's most valuable resource.
I'm just trying to find my mom.
She's the one that feeds me, she vacuums the house.
Come on!
On March 11th.
Man, Mars needs botox.
Get ready...
Guys, I've got the ship under control. I'm good.
Don't come any closer, I know karate. Well, at least on the Wii.
...for the mother of all adventures.
I dig it when you change color.
What?
How do we get past all those Martians?
Duh, fire butt blasters. This thing is going on the Christmas list.
Mars Needs Moms.
Dude, you march like a girl.
In 3D.
March 11.